[Music]
happy New Year for we might be drunk and
we're really doing it we had a hell of a
holiday season and we're not done yet
2024 Sam's behind the bar what should we
drink I'm feeling a big fat Negron oh my
God it's I was hoping for Negron all
right I had one yesterday and I was like
might it might be my favorite
cocktail at the moment wow okay well how
do you feel about a Negron I love to
Gran but that that that's a good point
cuz cocktails go in and out sometimes
I'm like vodka martini dirty all day and
then I'm like yeah give me a Manhattan
and then I want to eggnog with
bourbon so who knows eggnog is like one
day a year for me one day a year and
you're foam it's a pure
miscarriage with that nog so as we know
this is one part jyn one part vermouth
and one part compari easy drink to make
good this is when I get my gin intake
for the year I'm not a Jin guy you know
good Jin is good though monkey
is it monkey 47 or
uhoh throw out that I thought we used a
fake one for Phil Hamley didn't we cuz
we couldn't find it and we just put the
sticker on it isn't that what we did and
he was like I've never seen that bottle
shape before we're like it's not real
you idiot yeah yeah we faked a
uh a Jin for Phil Hanley so tell he
didn't know this he didn't notice the
difference told everything everybody's
full of with the liquor I did a
taste off with Michael Chay once and
Gray Goose and uh like pop off vodka and
he couldn't tell the difference pop off
is it is trash though it's trash you'll
tell the difference the next morning
that's when you really know when you're
uh that was the I used to drink in
college that was like oh yeah when
you're suicidal we used to mix that
with countrytime
lemonade the powder that's like maybe
the worst hangover ever youever make
like cheap sangria where you're like o
you do like the uh this is sweet right
yeah d uh you do the this cheap Sangria
with like all the what was it
what was the box wine oh frania
frania you know uh sangria means blood
isn't that weird that's how hardcore the
Hispanics are they're like yeah we're
drinking blood over
here is that is that what they call
periods I'm on my sangria ah are they
the Crips and the sangrias all right
they should put a Tamp on in for
garnish
Bloody Mary should do that they got
everything else in there okra lemon
shrimp
celery yeah I don't know about in New
Orleans carried away some of these
yeah they'll put a stick of
bacon in there sometimes New Orleans
they put an oyster crawfish gets out of
hand oh we got The Big Cube look at that
Cube ho I guess it's not a cube it's a
sphere do we we got only one left what
do we do for Round We got more in the FR
I love that goddamn Circle that is is a
beauty woo it's offensive to the Titanic
survivors all right Iceberg I always say
best Jewish rapper name
Iceberg okay there we go wow that's a
that's a goodl looking neg grown and and
not a that's a single right there it's
an easy one to make what's it JY
vermouth and compari okay they have all
these weird thank you they have all
these weird
variations uh the Americano that's like
compar M and soda they got the uh what
else cheers let's do a toast it's New
Year's right toast to the New Year hey
we never do this we never get
sentimental even though it's a drinking
pod weirdly we're good
drunks but another good year sure hell
yeah they've all been good but everybody
does that horse where they go 2023
worst year ever hope the next year's
better how about you make it better I
love I'm coughing the second I say good
to you second night the second night
toast you I get the whooping
cough got chera I get some organ Trail
illness to kill me uh damn no but
another good year good for we get to
work with each other yeah which is like
I never thought we'd be able to tore off
our drinking that's true hell yeah I
thought we'd have to quit at some point
but we actually we I think we've gotten
better we're not like you be either
become a a decent Drinker you become a
problem right or you have to quit all
together yeah that's a good point we we
had a we had a a fork in the road of
problem and quit and we said ah we'll go
down A New Path and and just live with
it and do do good at it which is what
some people say behind the wheel New
Path yeah we're going through the woods
we're going to the playground another
good year and next year's going to be
better I think I got some we got some
cooking oh yeah we'll see big
things in motion wheels are in motion
this was your best year ever for both of
you right careerwise ah well the
marriage took me down a peg that was
rough but yeah it was tough to lose him
too yeah no it was it was about it was
the first year for me in theaters I
think it was your first year in theaters
too right yeah I think so yeah it was it
was fun it was a I'm good I I I feel
secure yes you know until the kitty porn
disc comes out I'm good for a while I
got I'm cooking for a while yeah I like
how it's still on
disc that's a long I was younger too
that that might save
you but yeah no you're right good year
Netflix nflix my Netflix was year before
Oh okay working on new stuff new stuff
still still writing you can see the
photo there by the way we got a lot of
complaints about how we can't the
audience can't see the screen do so
we're sitting there going this and that
and this and that and they're like well
we don't see what you're seeing okay
that's I read the comments oh maybe I'll
stop reading them yeah what That's a
classic man this where it started this
is actually when you started your pod we
went and did this photo shoot oh that's
right that's right yeah that was the old
pod idea nothing better than a good
diner man you get get your eggs you get
your C even at night eggs oh
yeah that was the Fourth Street Diner is
that what it's called W Waverly
Washington Washington Square oh Waverly
is two blocks up is yeah yeah this is
the shittier version is it shittier is
it Diner I like it but Waverly is a
little better quality I'd say can I tell
you a peeve already today out of the
gate out of the gate cuz I okay so I did
Rush my passport you know it's like the
the the website Rush my passport so you
you know the plan is to rush the
passport I get my passport back it
wasn't going to expire till next
November but I was like let's get ahead
of it I might go do some gigs abroad
before then yeah so I do Rush my
passport I tried to go to the post
office first cuz I'm like it who
cares the woman was awesome she she gave
me your number she was like here's my
number so don't do it yet cuz I was
trying to get it back quickly and I
still had to go to Canada or something
before this she was like I'll give you
my number I text her call her I think
she gave me a fake number I think I got
a number from her I was like uh
you know trying to call whatever so now
I do Rush my passport we go to the uh
wait where you going you leaving the
state the country no according to rush
my passport I'm going to Mexico that
they were like you should give him a
place so they have to really expedite it
by December 25th so I had to pretend I
was like you ruined my trip to Mexico on
the phone today I had to pretend because
they call me and they go your photo
doesn't work I I like what do you mean
they're like we tried the does that mean
it doesn't work your photo it's like not
our our scanners aren't getting your
face we can't recognize your face and I
was like well uh this could be a bit I
was like well I you know I sent it
already I you know I send you a picture
and they go well we need another one I
was like what it's going to be of me
again it's gonna same face right and I
you not as I'm on the phone yelling
some guy walks by and he goes love your
and I was like he recognized my
face she didn't know what I was talking
about yeah but but uh but I had to go
and retake the pictures again today and
now I'm worried I'm in a hoodie
sweatshirt cuz I was just on the street
and I'm like are they going to send
a back some in a hoodie can you wear a
hoodie the hood wasn't up oh you're fine
you're fine yeah I look angry in the
picture too it's not with these eyebrows
you don't want to look angry in a
passport photo and I I look cranky yeah
and the turban didn't
help I was shouting praise a lot but
they didn't hear that so I think I'm
good there but they're you know what
they're going to have in a few years
probably you like you know you hold down
on like the live photo maybe they that
on the passport you hold down and the
guy's just like ah that guy's trouble
right yeah some uh license plates have
have a a hologram so that'd be kind of
funny if you could be
like you know like holding a beer bottle
or something like this yeah yeah well
Rush my pet what you trying to leave no
I just want a passport it's for me I
didn't cuz I was like it was like a
couple hundred extra bucks and I was
like it'll just give me piece of Mind
have it back and you never know like
sometimes someone calls up and like hey
we got a thing in we got a corporate in
Canada you know you never know so I just
for me it was peace of mind but uh but I
waited till I got back from Australia to
really do it and it's just been one
thing after another that kind of is
my my nightmare like anything logistical
or like government
run shoot me in the dick I can't handle
it isn't it weird that government our
government like go un Yelp or any of
them and it's like
2.3 if it was if it was a restaurant you
would never eat tot oh% at the rest our
government like it's the worst they
don't pay him enough they're cranky
they're poorly run like it's amazing
that you go to the post office then you
go to the CVS and you're like this is
good service yes CVS compared to the
post office ain't bad I know cuz they're
paying them it's like FedEx versus UPS
it it's night and day you go to the post
office or the DMV how sad is the DMV
bring a book bring a book bring a a
cyanide pill cuz you're going to want to
kill yourself after that DMV this whole
thing could be done in two seconds but
we got to do the grab a deli ticket wait
for your your number you're in there
with a crying baby and a meth head it's
brutal man that Deli ticket really it's
got range either the DMV or Russ and
Daughters you know it's like you're
either about to have the best salmon
spread of your life or it's going to
smell like
fish I missed this I missed I kind of I
like a guest lless episode every once in
a while every now you got to do it it's
like your wife get rid of the
the third every now and then every a
while rarely rarely and and every once
in a while you bring in a yeah
that's a two and a half some Two and a
Half
Men um yeah man uh but that it drove me
nuts I gotta I got a a movie Rec few I
don't know if I've done this stop me if
I have okay have you seen the movie A
Simple Plan yes wait a minute it's a Sam
Ry movie it's incredible who is that
Michael Douglas no it's uh Bill Paxton
Billy Bob thordon Bridget Fonda some
other guy who was great Bo that's a 9s
cast right there dude it's
amazing all right it's one of the best
movies I've seen in Forever what guy you
watching that I go through like best Neo
Noir lists online and I watched another
one after this it was also great called
um what was it called uh one false
move and it's also Bill Paxon and Billy
Bob thordon from the 90s and it's Billy
Bob wrote it wow it's really good really
it's another Neo Noir it's violent as
you know who directed it that guy
Carl Franklin who did um Devil in a Blue
Dress oh really yeah's really cool
director like it's it's beautiful shots
and uh and cool like just cool looking
and and it's cool when you notice the
direction but it doesn't take you out of
it right right but uh yeah it's great
and uh a simple plan is like incredible
I love a snowy Noir yeah like Fargo
which might be a year before this uh so
simple plan is basically two brothers
live in the sticks and they find a crash
plane with drug money on it and how it
starts breaking up the family breaking
up the trust between them one of is like
slow and something's off of at him it's
Billy Bob he's amazing in it he
had a run of slow
characters that sling blade you know he
wanted I am Sam he was like have I not
proven myself yeah
exactly oh wow look at this is this is a
this is a great premise already it's
great and it's you know what though it's
like there's a lot of cliches they could
have fallen into with this and they
avoid all of them it's like it's
unpredictable and it's uh there's just
not a a step like every scene worked and
mattered and and the dialogue is so
real it's it's just incredible
is this the one where Billy Bob says
think bad and bad's what you get I don't
remember that line well what's great
about these movies is they don't really
make these anymore where it's just a
movie about a story now everything's got
to have a message or like a you know
like some kind of virtuous moment a
lesson this is just like this crazy
thing happened and it's pretty
interesting entertaining I think you'll
like it Co spense time yes and
it's like you there's a moral decision
you deci you make usually the bad one
and let's see what happen do you get
away with it yeah and it's a decision
that makes sense it's a decision that
you're like I could see myself doing
this this is It's
relatable uh it's so good dude it's a
it's a it's worth a watch I'm hooked
also another wreck I got a double wreck
for you I I read a lot of
Noir for somehow I never read the black
dollia recently it's incredible really
it's so good I've only seen the
movie True Story I Heard the movie sucks
it was okay it was it was Josh haret
right yeah just a weird pick for like a
for like a Harden Pi he's he's fine but
it's just it's good dude really
yeah Elroy rules oh there you go hey
there she is Dana G's obsessed with the
black doia he's obsessed with a lot of
the I'm obsessed with like we Bond
over a lot of he loves Elroy he got me
to read Elroy I photographed Elroy
really
what in the late 90s and he was dropping
I don't know if I can say this word
racist
words two of us yeah well word it was
like starts with a J Ah that's a classic
casually yeah old school racist I was
like Wow because it's like you were born
with this and it just never you never
shook it well he had a crazy life I
think his mom was killed and they didn't
solve the murder so it's like talk about
an origin story for either like a
detective or a true crime type writer
but
Roy
my it's so good highly recommend
I mean he any of his is pretty cool
but uh hell yeah but that's just like
pure Noir Dude That's a classic
Hollywood Starlet who was killed yeah
and if you know what it's kind of like
that uh I don't want to say revisionist
history but I guess it kind of is where
it's like kind of his version of what
happened and uh you know it's it's an
obviously an unsolved murder
this is what he this is his take on it
real easy to get away with a murder back
in the day you shoot somebody you walk
away that's about it you know there's no
camera as long as you got a mask on
you're good that's why those that's why
those books kind of only work in that
era mhm cuz now it's like now you feel
like there's going to be we're like a
year away from like the Tik Tock
murderer guys just going to be like he's
like all right you got you looking at
this oh let me get it focused on us
all right pow you know yeah well they
had the uh the Tupac killer came out on
Tik Tock and he got busted they just got
him they just got him CU of Tik Tok he
was like yeah I'm the guy who did it woo
it's such a lame ending to one of the
most I mean it's just one of the most
famous dudes getting assassinated rock
as a as a bit they weren't ass he goes
uh them two nword got shot that's a
great bit JFK was assassinated Martin
Luther King was assassinated they got
shot yeah that's a great I remember
where I was when that that Tupac crawl
was on the bottom of the MTV screen
Tupac Shakur shot in Vegas I was in my
my house in New Orleans in my bedroom
with like four guys we' just gone
skateboarding and we came back we're
watching skate videos but we had MTV on
in the background and then it just
breaking news CTT loader you know damn
CT loader remember that guy oh yeah that
was old school him and who is the other
guy Matt something pfield yeah oh I saw
a guy in a I was underage drinking in a
bar once and he was in there and he
couldn't have been nicer we were kids
and he was just like I think he
was smoking a joint in the bar wow and I
was like this dude's insane he
was he was just very friendly we were
kids I mean why would you want to talk
to an underage kid in a bar but he was
very friendly yeah well I think I know
why he invited me back to his place he
gave me a kiss on the neck it was he was
very uh very cool he was the heavy metal
guy right legendary um music deaths um I
just heard a story about Kurt Cobain oh
that the trans he killed himself you
didn't
hear the trans Community is trying to
claim him huh yeah how so because he
wore a lot of dresses Okay so did
Rodman skirt Cobain hey my Norman I love
it that was great oh my God I did I did
a joke in in Buffalo this week and uh I
was riffing with a guy and this woman
tells a story about getting attacked in
the crowd she said I got attacked by a
guy with clams you know like he was
throwing clams at me on the B bus in
Buffalo not a happy tale but uh but she
goes clams and some guy yells out
Calamity and I go easy Norman and that
killed it got a big Pop I was like the
we might be drunk o are out yeah I
didn't mean to cut you off with the
Trans thing though also in a suicide
note it said uh I'm tired of Faking
it oh oh interest I think he mean I
meant think he meant happiness and
celebrity I thought so too yeah I think
Courtney might have chimed didn't wrote
that part
yeah damn I had another uh speaking of
Norman I told him earlier but uh we were
at a airport restaurant and this Muslim
lady kept yelling at the waiter and my
friend goes she's a real Karen and I
went she's Muslim she's more of a Karan
oo that's good so yeah that was my
highlight that's hilarious yeah
Karan that's good try to put that in the
ACT somewhere but it's not easy more of
a COR no there's a way to do it all
right well um speaking of peeves I got a
peeve
also Simple Plan wasn't there a a Cohen
a simple serious man good movie a simple
death I think it's their first movie
Blood Simple Blood Simple that's a good
movie that's what I was thinking yeah
but Dan hidea yeah which guy's that the
lead actor he no he's a really hairy guy
okay yeah he was in some stuff yeah he's
in a lot of good good character actor
man who else is in that uh but I
think that's their First's in that yeah
look at that
I got some polls I I could hang in in
movie pong em Walsh that's the guy he's
great in everything he's always great
he's in like the jerk he's in um talking
about you can't do today holy
uh a lot of scenes in that movie you
ain't pulling off anymore a lot of nword
but goddamn it works in the movie It's
soem EMT Walsh she's in like he's still
alive isn't he oh yeah wow he he has not
looked well in at least 40 years that's
true he's a he's like a great character
where born in third 35
wow what else is he in he's in like so
much holy 35 like a lot of
Classics he's so funny in The Jerk yeah
jerk I watched that two weeks ago still
still funny so good so good just
a poor black boy Blade Runner it says
okay there you go blood blood simple is
great con brothers are legends
yeah we need a new one cohens come on
well one of them's done right I think
one of them why I don't know
just he just
retired uh all right peeve now this is a
this is not as good as the the the
passport one but just throwing it out
there you ever get the guy who
apologizes for something but keeps doing
it oh yeah so I had the guy on a plane
I'm sitting on a plane a guy goes hey
you know fan whatever I listen to this I
go great I appreciate it hell yeah we
got a photo on the on the plane he's in
the other aisle I'm in the one row
there's an aisle than him and he goes
sorry to keep bugging you man
but and then he's like sorry about
bugging you but and you're like you're
not sorry that's what pisses me off
you're not sorry because you can't just
apologize and then do the thing you know
you keep doing it after the apology it
doesn't the apolog is meaningless now
yeah because you're still just doing the
same thing if you were actually sorry
you'd be like I got to stop doing that
yeah you got to say I'm sorry I can't
stop doing this but I guess so but yeah
he just doesn't care he doesn't care
yeah and uh it it just killed me cuz he
kept apologizing the the problem is you
got to go no it's okay it's okay and
then he would do the thing so he gets
you with the apology because then you go
no it's all good and then he kept
doubling down me horrible people should
do that you're just like you're just
like a Mugger and you're like I'm so
sorry to do this but I'm going to I'm
going to rob you again I'm sorry I I
missed something give me the watch too
give me the in your pocketbook yeah the
English do that they're like I feel
terrible sorry but you're a it's
like why you say sorry say yeah you
called me a don't it yeah that's uh
yeah that's that's a reasonable P of the
the repeat offender yes with the sorry
yeah I'm okay if you if you just keep
offending whatever but the repeat like
if he kept talking to me I'll I'm fine
with it I want to talk to the guy
whatever but the sorry was killing me
well the manners are not sincere to you
yes or they're not sincere in general
that's why it bothers you EXA exactly
and then another peeve is do you have a
friend who can't articulate so
everything is called a thing he was like
oh man I was in the thing or earlier and
I'm like what what thing and he's like
you know the uh I was like the cab the
Uber Uber okay well he said thing I
don't know what thing is and he's like
and then I you know I had to get my wife
to sign the thing and I'm like what sign
what he's like you know the divorce
paper ass I'm like divorce paper you
called it a thing like you got to come
up with your before you I'm holding
the thing and you're like the the
machete he's like yeah and I'm trying to
kill her give it to me you need you got
to you got to come up with the words
before you start telling these crazy
stories yeah that that bugs me too a man
Seinfeld has that great bit you know the
bit I'm talking about where where it's a
thing and uh no no Seinfeld has a bit I
love where he goes uh what was I saying
he goes oh so you weren't paying
attention either it's a great it's like
the most concise way to make a point
while that's great great but uh he's so
good at those little he's got that one
he's like uh if you see Bob tell him I
said hello it's like what am I a
messenger in Middle Ages hello from Dave
that's the scroll yeah I think Demetri
had a bit like that too like in the age
of text you need me to ask act as a
messenger is that Seinfeld no that's
that's not him you know it's also uh
Jerry's just in like a constant state of
irritation and that's F right it's like
no matter how rich he is he's I just
watched the episode of Lou he's in it's
such a good EP oh I don't remember you
know the Country Club episode Lou does
the Hampton's gig and and he eats
and Jerry then goes up and trashes them
it's like a classic I don't remember
that oh it's it's one of the best
episodes of Louis really yeah and uh
it's just hilarious like he goes up eat
L he shows up dressed like crap and
Jerry's in a tuxed oh come on like
really he goes Country Club benefit oh
yeah I do remember that Louis walks in
and eats they put a security guard
Blazer on him so then uh so then Jerry
goes on and goes oh that was the worst
thing I've ever seen like just
completely turns on him oh you know it's
a great app no sorry what's so crazy
about the the old Lou and Jerry stuff is
Lou opened for Jerry in the 80s in
Boston and Lou was like you know a year
in or whatever and Jerry was like this
big comic and they were at some Banquet
Hall you know it's a bunch of Boston
townies shitfaced Rowdy the room's half
full and and Jerry Louie goes well maybe
we should start at like 8:30 because you
know it's 8:00 now and you know the
room's half full and I'm opening and
Jerry goes no no we're starting on time
and he's like well there's no one here
he's like that's why you're the opener
and Lou was like geez Jesus Christ and
he never forgot it wow well I guess
that's I mean I wouldn't do that to
someone opening to me personally but uh
yeah that's cuz we bring our buddies to
open I don't want Gary eating in
that spot right also it kind of affects
your set too yeah that's what I thought
but I think he was just like no no I'm a
professional so you got to be a
professional Jerry's a stickler he's a
stickler everything has to be organized
and into his you know whatever he finds
to deem acceptable but it's like has to
be any I feel like that's part of the
irritation yeah anything breaks from
what he thinks is the schedule he's like
no exactly and people go like well
that I would never and you're like well
then don't work with him yeah I'm
willing to deal with that I'll work with
him it's his show I don't know if it was
my show he would I feel like he would
succumb to your dictatorship I start
shows late all the time I shouldn't even
say that cuz people going to show up
even later but like well you want a full
room you want a full room and I mean
godamn some cities like Miami can you
show up not 30 minutes late it's like
the worst
for Baltimore's bad too oh they start
late we did the lyric and it was woo
here we go well maybe we'll go 7:15 may
go 720 I mean we just kept pushing damn
was the lyric fun
killer beautiful room yeah great room
great town Baltimore downtown is
stunning but it's beautiful on the water
two inches out and you're in the wire
also those weird walkways one misstep
you fall in the water you're a
icicle yeah everyone talks about the
crime there but I'm like you could you
could just die a dumb death that's true
yeah you're eating a crab cake you're
like is that
Sam all right what do you got the you
got the Jerry scene oh I don't think so
I have something but I te
Google boy over here what the I don't
know no this is this is the
benefit oh that's not it I might have to
rewatch Louie oh it's so good man that
David Lyn shark is so good oh that was
great when he's trying to host something
man it's uh it's killer I I rewatch it
and I feel like I rewatch it all the
time just cuz it's like it's also like
my kind of New York yes I just love how
he shoots New York like it's the way he
does it like the construction guys just
like not just banging on his window but
then they're in aart his apartment just
like hitting him it's like that's very
Woody Allen too I love that yeah you
know Louie was uh drove a motorcycle
around Manhattan and then got hit by a
car recently no no no uh back when he
was like doing sets before no yeah in
the show he did something like that I
know that was real oh yeah true story
yeah I haven't seen him around in a
while well he he's our neighbor taking a
year off I saw him about I saw flower
moon with him oh nice and then I walked
home and I saw him with a pretty hot
lady oh I saw him on the street Oh I
thought you went to go see it with him
no I saw it with him oh okay the cou I
got let me let me run I got some bit
ideas to buy you going right in by the
way I saw the holdovers I heard it's
great I enjoyed it I enjoyed it too why
why why do you say it like that because
we have some friends who like to
poo poo every goddamn piece of art yeah
basically ran said he liked it I know he
came to me apologetic for liking it too
and I was like what is list doing to
people well it is a little I would I
don't want to say sappy but it's a very
emotionally Huggy feely kind of
tearjerker Alexander Payne's a
Legend man I think he one of the best
ever I love that line I don't want to
give too much away but they go into the
city it's like a Catholic like a what do
you call it like a private school
private school kid they go into the city
City and he start he gets into it with a
Towny in a bar and they go what's up
fancy boy and he goes back to Paul GM
goes we got to get out of here these
guys just called me
fancy there some great lines in it I
mean it's really funny it's it's it's
super sad like so buckle up it's one of
those where you're like all right pay
take it easy because at least sideways
had more comedy than than election yeah
and election election was awesome
election is one of the funniest movies
I've ever seen but it's good I like it
but it's it's a tearjerker okay I'm
going to check it out yeah all right I'm
trying to think what else that's is that
a w is it a wck that's a wreck I'm
Wrecking it we just need some movies out
you know we got uh Napoleon the bed
did you I saw Shane tweeted he loved it
was he being was he drunk or was he I
talked to him about it I think we both
likeed I still enjoyed it just cuz it's
such an epic did you see it with him no
I didn't he's he's in Texas I saw it
here but it's still an epic and you're
like oh my God it's still Wen it's still
Ridley Scott so it's still a sight A
Feast for the senses but I just as a
story it didn't come together he's such
a history that like he can't look
at something and be like why is wen's
Phoenix speaking an American accent like
I'm sure that bothered him bothered who
Shane you said Shane Shane loved it he
liked it he liked he liked it but it's
got a lot of inaccuracies it's
historically wrong in a lot of ways they
added a bunch of but like 86 yeah
yeah exactly it's weird to make like a a
big scale epic when you're like 80
out there in the snow with cannons and
cannonballs and muskets and I mean
he's older than Biden and he's out there
directing that's pretty good and Biden's
in the too he's visiting Israel so
well much like Europe they both fell all
right what about
uh what is it like entertaining or is it
what I mean which one no Napoleon bid's
full that's entertaining hter Biden's
the most
entertaining no uh Napoleon is is an
entertaining movie I was love I loved it
I was on the edge of my seat but I saw
it alone in the theater in the big uh
big screen on the road uh yeah dude it's
uh it's one of the things where like has
there been a big Napoleon movie before
he's such a great character to there was
one in like 1917 it's called Napoleon 17
1917 I me look it up no there's a later
one than that I think there's a 70s they
do one every every hundred years or so I
mean that's sounds like it what
what was that movie I saw with me and
the wife saw movie and it sucked what oh
what the hell did we go see oh oh uh
Thanksgiving what's that that's the one
with Tim Dylan no off Tim's great and
this he he got some laughs out of the
the audience in the in the room but it's
like a horror movie right yeah just you
know I'm not a big horror guy I'm not
either there's no development there's no
characters there's no nothing I know but
it's cool that Tim got like a comic role
in a in a Ked killed it and they cut his
head off feel like Tim could be like a
big actor oh yeah oh yeah he's so
funny he you watch him on screen
you're like he belongs there there was
no hesitation oh nice a genuine
sensation 1927 sorry 27 okay still so
it's a silent film I'm guessing whoa it
actually looks kind of cool for back
then great and that looks more like
Napoleon than Wen does
true ooh we got a brown low restoration
wow look at that it is amazing that you
can I mean but also amazing to think of
what movies were just like 10 years
after this right I know like
Philadelphia Story is what like 39
that's a decade after this right I mean
it's amazing wow this is incredible I
mean this is back in this yeah it's
also amazing when you think of these
movies like from the old school like
Battleship batkin and the influence they
have were like okay the Untouchable
still wants to rip off a scene
in that you know it's like you can take
influence from this stuff but some of
them are hard to watch like you try to
watch movie if it's not like chaplain or
Buster Keon being like just fall down
funny some of them are tough like it'd
be hard to sit through a silent film
totally but for Scorsese this is like
watching prior or something you know
it's like watching old Abid a Castello
or something but Fritz Lang made like
metropolis and then he made like the
big heat which one would you
rather watch yeah right I mean it's like
a badass cop movie or just a silent you
know true true damn I had something I
lost it you threw me off with that we're
movie nerds I got it back pull
this up hit me speaking of Scorsese you
know the hot lady in Christmas Vacation
that's at the mall who lifts her skirt
up yeah you know what I'm talking about
the the brunette I don't I like I
remember it a little but I don't know I
can't place her face pull up hot lady at
the department store should we do
another drink or yes Christmas Vacation
what we drink in this round same drink I
I'd like another negr all right another
can we can we can you get us more ice
Matt sorry Matt yeah that lady I just
need we just need one more Cube salak do
you not want to drink I'll take one all
right so let's do two more cubes do you
remember her this hot lady no you don't
remember her and I'm sorry for not
offering before just she never drank but
I figured it's a special occasion
special occasion she was the lingerie
girl that's a
scorsi she she is 70 years old
today that's all this woman said me yeah
yeah wait what are you talking about
this woman in Christmas vacation who I
had a huge crush on as a kid and she's
what score Stacey I think she's a she's
related to Martin oh my God I don't know
it's a there she she's hot dude oh she's
super hot you can see the Italian on her
mug there for sure but uh she lifts her
skirt up it was super hot he goes crazy
she looks like a honey baked H but she's
hot yeah the80s triple horn which is
giving me some weird she was a
piece Bas Instinct really for years for
decad isn't it weird when you're like
check out my girlfriend it's just like
your mom
isn't that weird when you just pick
someone who looks exactly like everyone
in your family I've done it there's a
lot of that you see like Happy Father's
day and every girl they post their dad
and they all look like their boyfriend
oh dude I I remember I used to do a bit
about this about how like triple what I
don't find her attractive oh she back in
the day she was a piece dude but uh but
but I used to have a bit about this like
you bring a home a woman home it looks
exactly like your mom and your mom's
like I don't like her and your dad's
like I think she's
great and then you mom you're like yeah
of course you don't like her she's you
right I feel like my dad would go the
other way I don't like
her he sick of my mom but yeah I'm
telling you that girl's a scorey and
she's 70 today M over he also dated
Ilana Douglas that's I met Iana Douglas
I'm an idiot okay dude she was she was
great she's always great uh R Cape Fear
she uh oh dude that rape scene
Jesus Christ isn't it weird to be dating
someone and then be like you're going to
get raped by Robert Ziro in this scene I
mean that's weird that is weird
do we have an extra glass too here take
mine oh yeah oh there we go you're the
best Matt thank you bro Matt do you want
to drink I mean what are we doing here
are you sure you never touch them Peters
it's New
Year's
whoa that'd be great if Peters was just
on drugs this entire time he's on acid
he thinks this is are you
garbage by the way I up the name
Ilana Douglas and I'm standing by my
thought though look at the pictures
about they look Alik scors sister is
that his sister though I don't know we
find give you got to you got to goog
that Cube I think we go fresh Cube got
to go fresh Cube Ice Cube Sal Cube yeah
Gleaming the Cube you get the name check
yourself cubic aronium all right um but
scorsi Vegas or Christmas
Vacation uh hot lady I don't know good
luck nice lady
nicholet that's a hot name nicholet
Sheridan oh she was hot remember oh
yeah um but yeah all right second NE
gron you got spots tonight three yeah I
got a few I got four yeah Liz is not
going to be happy with me no I think I'm
somebody cancelled cuz I got a few of
hers really I got one of hers too n910
yeah yeah that's the one I couldn't do
oh nice there you go I had two already
it fit perfectly I think I'm like 820
850 and 910 I'm like talk about a
perfect night are you 820 at this this
the Olive Tree I don't know okay I'm 810
at the Olive Tree I think we're back to
back Jacks baby there you go noblock
let's do it listen to this run by uh our
scores lady Nicollet nicholet no no wait
uh yeah nicholet scorsi dated Antonio
Sabato Jr and then sea Penn
wow I bet he'd be a annoying
boyfriend oh yeah like passionate
intense I got to go down to New Orleans
and sit in a canoe and shoot people you
know with my shotgun I'm going to
Venezuela this week yeah about what next
week Ukraine yeah after that I'm going
to chill in Gaza for a little while
right right then I got to go meet the
cartel in Mexico I think he actually did
meet that guy but yes yeah Al Chapo
Chapo that's how they got Choo no way
get out of here yes what they uh he gave
his location away in the Sean pen
interview
whoa that's hilarious you think like in
a moment you're like I get to meet Shawn
pen that just ruins your
life I am Sam you me Sean pen
that guy you know what he needs
to do is a comedy yeah is so I'm taking
myself so seriously well do a comedy
well he started with uh spikowski or
whatever SPI but I mean a new comedy
yeah cuz clearly he can do comedy I know
he's he's a talent I mean he can do a
tart a pothead
a bad guy a good
guy naming people
a just pointing at things I see yeah
it's like when you're on the phone
you're like oh I got to go uh Bodega
cat's in the
room bye boder cat I feel like we're
making progress dude I got hit up by a
distributor also so I set up a meting
dude it's going to happen we'll knock
that out I'll tell you we're all right
you know oh yeah I'll tell you you know
you have a drinking problem when you
when you find an Olive in your urine
sandle
tell I can't stop thinking about that uh
Dangerfield thing he told me about how
he didn't go on uh on Rogan in the 70s
and talk about Nyah I'll tell you about
I'll tell you about Nixon yeah yeah this
guy's a crook all right I've been
throwing that around all over town oh
yeah I mean that's it's just different
times man yeah yeah well luckily I'm an
idiot I'm working on a bit about how
George Santos is actually Santa so
that's that's that's the surface level
of politics I keep it at 2024 is going
to stink uh I hate when people do the
year thing you know what I hate when
well when people say that like next year
this is a bad year next year's going to
be bad that's what you're saying or next
year's going to be great or next year's
going to be bad it's like says who you
can't just throw out what people I'll
give that to is people who have had a
particularly bad year the people like I
need a good year next year right I'll
give it to those people where they're
like it's like a coping mechanism yeah
they're like I got diagnosed with feline
AIDS in 2022 that was a bad year like
all right I'll give you that I told you
that in
confidence it's a little rude I thing
what I hate it when people are like uh
like Prince dies and they're like
2019 sucks yeah they year yeah
they Year yes exactly exactly God got
off the phone with a year and he's like
you got this one ah I know also 2019
looking back pretty good year no
pandemic no riots good times that smells
good oo look at you having a cocktail
dad there you go well it's
Friday all right there you go okay what
are you guys doing for the hall you
going uh you going to stay in the city I
guess I don't have real plans I yeah for
me like a a vacation is not leaving my
apartment that's nice that's like all I
want I don't want to get in a flight I
don't do I want to see some good
movies in the theater and by man my
favorite thing to do this time of year
like it's a wonderful life at
IFC like like that I did that last
year oh you know what I got a
holiday wreck and it's the holidays are
over by the time this comes out
unfortunately but like you know it's a
good not good movie but I love
it Jingle All The Way never seen it dude
Sinbad's in that I Sinbad's
incredible wow okay it's about an action
figure is it a great movie no but I
it's like a weird like it's like a weird
Comfort movie I was texting with Mike
Lawrence our buddy Mike Lawrence and he
like loves this movie and I I
love that movie movie Hell yeah all
right it's absurd it's such a simple
premise got the dad it's so
relatable the dad up he didn't get
the kid toy in time and Rita Rita Wilson
back in this time Dime Piece Phil Harman
incredible you seen it right a fun movie
right this a
96 and the kid's
adorable classic Schwarzenegger yeah 96
wow she was was
cute
music yeah it's all base Phil
Hartman kills it yeah there's a Chris
Parnell Cameo wow Sim simbad is great a
mailman and so is uh it's so simple and
stupid but it's like a war it's like a
calming movie yeah I'll tell you next
movie we might we write Christmas movie
really well they kill it they all kill
it and it plays every it plays every
year you know like this Eddie Murphy one
I haven't seen a lick of it but it's
doing crazy numbers you know people need
it it's like a comfort
thing yeah it is and you need something
to watch you're with your dumb family
you hate each other you got to put
something on it's like the Super Bowl
it's a day it's a day you know you will
hopefully get peace yes you do a classic
clean comedy I mean we put on Love
Actually every goddamn year and I want
to blow my brains out Kain my there's
like the Christmas classics like the
obvious ones like It's a Wonderful Life
the great ones but like bad Santa and
jingle all the way that's my rotation I
always watch those the crazy about Bad
Santa is he her in the ass that's
what's great about Bad Santa they they
go what they could have just had public
sex but he has to go now let's her
in the ass it's even naughtier yeah he's
a bad guy yeah he's a bad s he enjoyed
that it hurt her yeah he was not a good
plus that little person's great and
oh yeah Bernie Mack and Ritter
man John Ritter rip hell yeah man we
just devolve into movie talk constantly
on this I know you throw a in you
can't lose that fat kid was great with
the the curly blonde hair he's
that face you like can't let me try
a bit on you all right is this might be
terrible this bit all right this could
be a bad we might have to cut this one
oh I can't wait the hostages this is my
angle is like it must suck to be one of
the ones that doesn't get picked you
know like but like we're probably like
five years away from that being a
reality show you know what I mean we
have we have love as blind we don't have
hate as blind you know some guys the
contestants are blindfolded who knows
who get pick no Rhyme or Reason we just
know it won't be a
man is there something it's nothing I
love the hostage reality show I think is
the is great that might be something
maybe something with Squid game
something like that something let's go
to a different one all right but I like
the reality show so I saw a dog barking
at uh like crazy at a white guy in the
street and this black guy yells out yeah
that's right white people and I was
like was like I'm no psychologist this
might be a projection I don't know if
that's what the dog was saying for sure
so I think the angle is maybe like all
right to could play at this game I uh I
walked up to a pigeon I was like what
was that girl all lives matter
wow something like that yeah maybe a
white dove a white
dove a white dove might be better but
yeah that's funny you could just make
the animal say whatever you think also
that's what a what's that guy's
name Son of Sam did oh yeah the dog told
to kill him like oh that's convenient
rine had that funny joke who's not going
to listen to a talking who's not going
to listen to a talking dog oh it's a
great turn I didn't see that coming at
all what do you got you got some bits I
got bits baby do some holiday bits all
right has this been done uh I always me
and the lady we got to eat a lot you
know as you do as a couple and I always
like to Yelp the restaurant just like oh
let's see what we got here and they're
always crazy the reviews are never
helpful it's always like a just a
Bipolar person venting but I thought
wouldn't it be great if there was Yelp
for people you know like uh you know
your friend's like you got to meet Josh
you would love Josh and I'm like let me
read some reviews you know on Josh or
you know you go further with it like uh
you like if you you have sex with a girl
and take her virginity you just write
first that's funny something like so the
the joke would be just all the examples
definitely a laugh yeah that hits It's F
I guess there yel for people but it's
just famous people those are the ones
know where they like Wikipedia people
were like that guy oh publicly
right I guess that's kind of what Reddit
is already yeah but there's no scores I
like the idea that there's a score yeah
cuz we get raided on Uber we get raided
on like GrubHub or whatever but it'd be
nice if it just a Yelp for people it
would get ugly obviously you it' be nice
to be on a dating app and you're like
3.1 you're like but she is hot oh maybe
that's the angle you could rate on a
dating app yeah M maybe that's it I like
the idea that you like
like someone has a score cuz you have an
Uber score yeah this is more important
I'm I'm spending the whole night with
you this is a social Uber's 20 minutes
right I I might date you so I'd like to
know what I'm dealing with here yeah
like the Uber's like this guy might kill
me so could they yeah it's all
night you treat each other a lot better
if you're like you I don't want to hurt
my
rating okay she's about to slash her
tires I don't want to hurt my rating
that's good that's a good line okay
maybe that's something it's a Black
Mirror episode oh there's an episode of
that all right we just came up with a
thing that's already been
done sorry Black Mirror I don't I I've
seen like one episode I think I watched
the episode where the it's pretty good
show I watched the one where the where
the guy the pig oh that's a great
episode that was good I just never it's
not my genre but it was it was well done
I liked it all right how about this how
about a building where you can rent
books for
free that's the
joke there's a black mirror episode
about
that what uh what else you got okay all
right all right maybe that was that's a
little high concept all right how about
this that's a good Black Mirror idea we
just came up with a great idea that
they've already beat us
to okay okay how about this how about
this so I was hanging out with my buddy
we're going out to get some food and I
go what do you want to get pizza and he
goes ah I had pizza last night I was
like but you're like obsessed with pizza
and he goes I can have pizza two nights
in a row and I said well don't get
married um that's what marriage is
eating pizza every night for the rest of
your life and I'll tell you if you had
to eat pizza every night for the rest of
your life you get creative some nights
you're like I'll eat it from the
back then you're like I got thin crust
at home but sometimes I pretend it's a
deep dish or whatever I'm just trying to
think of uh other Pizza related sexual
innuendos yeah sometimes I get sometimes
I uh I'm in a bad mood I put it in the
fridge yeah I eat it in the morning yeah
eat in the morning's good all right I
had a line where I'm like I saw a
good-looking Taco earlier so when I got
home I folded the pizza pretended it was
that taco that's great it doesn't really
hit I think it's funny I think it needs
a a better way to say it but yeah yeah
man it's like
sometimes it's tough It's funny because
it like takes what you loved about pizza
and now it ruined it because it's so
common it's like yeah I used to
love pizza I was it was my favorite
thing but now that I have it every day
I'm just
like pizza is not that special to me
anymore right now you're like you look
at pad tie you're like I would
kill I know I would murder someone for a
piece of pad tie yeah I would
I'd murder someone for for a meatloaf
you know I'll take anything it just
sucks like what kind of food would let
you not enjoy other
food you know what I mean that's good
point you're like you're denying me the
pleasure of just
Adventure yeah it's crazy it's a crazy
concept marriage yeah but uh then you
see her looking at soul food you're like
you oh that's a good way
to go with it that's good she riing
she's looking at a kill Bosa I'm like
whoa wait a minute all right I love
pizza like that's a little big isn't it
she's like I think it would fit nicely
yeah she's like why don't we put it on
the pizza I'm like no no
no all right all right there's something
there now we're now we're talking I'll
tell you yeah what do I got um that's a
good way to go with it what does she
want to eat is this funny I I was
watching um I was watching that movie
The Age of Innocence Stacy movie you
know with Daniel de Lewis it's like old
timey tale of repression I think one of
the angles is like first of all like
there at these it was like very classy
to have bad seats at the Opera you're
like in the wings yeah you're in the
wings with those like fancy opera
glasses like yes okay you know but like
think about that now you go to a
sporting event you're in like the nose
bed with binocular it's like oh yeah
it's a nice rushing play you know
something like that or something like
that that was one angle maybe that's
nothing the other angle was uh because
it was like no being close to the action
was bad right you wanted to be in a
private booth oh I mean oh good point
yeah that's nothing here's the other
angle how they were so repressed they'd
go their whole lifetime just not acting
on their on their urges yeah right but
now you think of people now what's the
number one porn category stepmom yeah
you're like maybe maybe there's a middle
ground right maybe there's somewhere in
the middle right you know between you
know never doing what you wanted and
someone in your family yeah true
you know true I don't know huh well
something funny about those damn
binoculars they're like less cre like if
you got caught doing a Peeping Tom with
those you're like well at least he was
classy yeah that's true you like some
guy's in a tree with that you're
still like ah you know he's he's
cultured and he's far away in the top of
the tree yeah he's got box seats to my
bedroom yeah huh maybe this I think the
Stepmom thing is something the Stepmom
thing is something I this we need a
middle ground from like not having sex
till you're 40 to your family
member got to be something in the middle
there maybe we combine them all right
there's nothing let me try one more all
right I uh I'm going in the into a
building this building actually it
happened here and the security guard
stops me he's like hey hold on what
floor and I was like 16 he's like go
ahead I'm like that's it that's the
security I had to C the floor in the
building have nailed that yeah right I
just guess the floor I like that the
security is doing the same job as a as a
porno site oh yes I'm 18 go right ahead
something there maybe I don't know yeah
there's something there have you read
all the uh what is it do you agree to
all the you know the conditions
that's it terms and
conditions that's what uh Pat Dixon had
that old joke about the Bible it's like
yeah you like the Bible sure terms and
conditions check I agree with everything
but you never actually read it what do
you got um that's something there too
like imagine if women did that uh all
right how about this yeah uh well
somebody had that joke where like they
walk they go on a date with a girl they
walk her to the door and she's like
you're not going to rape me are you and
he's like no she's like all right come
on that was me was that you okay you're
not going to kill you're not going to
kill me are you I said no she goes all
right let's go back to you I was like J
and I go that's your screening process
that was it if I'm going to murder you
you just ask me like I couldn't fake
that see I guess I'm retreading My Own
yeah but this could go a different
way maybe don't bring women in that's a
you do a certain point in comedy where
you just start ripping off yourself oh
I've been there yeah yeah all right I'm
like Puerto
Rican there's more meat on this phone
let me revisit this um all right so uh
you know what's great about being
married is my wife is very nice like
I'll comedy will get you down you can't
find a new bit you're traveling you're
run down you're W you're beat and she's
like hey I get it but you got to stop
worrying about the destination the
journey is amazing it's all about the
journey the struggle is part of the fun
that's what life's about and I go that's
a good point and I always remind her of
that when she can't have an
orgasm you know I'm down there she's
like what the hell are you doing and I'm
like it's about the journey you know the
struggle is part of the fun but I can't
I need a turn so all that hits I just
got no ending yeah that's all good
unless you're trying to come basically
right right no one no one
uh yeah no one's looking for fulfillment
in bed yeah we all talk about this
journey this magical you know it's all
about going for it and don't worry about
the goal it's about this part but when
it comes to orgasming it's like all
about the destination yeah that's
something funny there is like it's
not
um I think it could be funnier if you're
just like uh she's like Jesus Christ
what the hell and you're like it's a
wild ride we're on you know yeah don't
expect it to end today this is like a
30-year thing right right yeah yeah it's
just like we're in for the Long Haul
yeah it's about
um you know she's telling her
girlfriends like I just I never finish
in bed and you know I'm like maybe your
friends are like yeah well that's the
Buddhist way or something yeah less is
more yeah the uh yeah the laoo the maybe
maybe that's the angle like no one wants
to hear philosophical quotes in bed you
know like boy you got a small dick less
is more you know or like well I just
want a bigger dick well it's not about
desires are bad you know or something
that's interesting yeah
like
for career it's one thing but in bed you
just want to come yeah it's Primal it's
like hey just you got to get this done
it's in bed is all about results you
know with philosophy that's a good line
results yeah philosophy is all about
like the bigger picture and the now and
whatever because it's not like you're
going to be on podcast talking about the
road to making your girlfriend come but
you will be talking about like the road
to where you got as a comedian right
like that's an inspiring tale no one
wants to be like there I was trying to
make her
come 10 years later I made it happen
right right well because sex is supposed
to be a finite amount of time whereas
like as you know career and life it's
kind of this open-ended thing well it's
like soccer versus bad basketball you
know like basketball there's a lot of
scoring you there should be a lot of
points on the board right soccer not a
lot of scoring but when it does it
really count basketball's good taking it
to the hole Yeah it's all about taking
it to the hole where soccer is all about
you know passing and relationships with
the teammates patience patience okay
this is something attacking picking your
spots right basketball is just non-stop
to the hole
Yeah getting that somewhere Rim okay you
got another one yeah oh you know it I
got one more and I'll leave you alone so
I'm I'm flying back from Buffalo and uh
great week by the way Buffalo's great uh
comedy shout out to mothers by the way
incredible restaurant courtesy of little
Gary uh Gary Veer who found it one of
the best steaks I've ever had in my life
really oh my God Buffalo's got great
food we also hit the Swan Street
Diner let me tell you just a great Diner
just like Buffalo it's a real town
There's Something About a box car type
din that just puts me at ease on the
road it I love a good diner I love
getting eggs in the morning getting just
cup after cup of coffee yeah same we
also have the best our fans are
so cool man yeah uh what's the
name of the M the trial someone from one
of our fans Newman no it's that's a
verdict that's a great movie too but
torrison Wells movie the trial with him
and Anthony Anthony Perkins I think we
talked about in the Pod someone leaves
me that DVD at the club wow so I have
the DD now it was the most thing and
just thoughtful it's a thoughtful gift
uh so I've never seen it it's Kafka I've
never seen the the oh I just watched the
trailer for this get out of here it's
supposed to be incredible and it's Orson
Wells and Anthony Perkins who
are just that looks so good and it's
60 years old yeah I mean look
how Co it's supposed to be incredible
and I can't wait to watch it but like I
mean Anthony Perkins we talked about him
just like an incredible actor who was
derailed by being gay back then and I
think cast from Norman Bates as well
sure but I mean dude he died from AIDS
oh yeah his wife dies in 911 can you
imagine I didn't know that your parents
your parents die AIDS in 9/11 wow that's
brutal wow man he was an
incredible actor though but he just got
typ cast because of yeah you know crazy
my wife works at a magazine in the
visuals department and she says this
gets brought up all the time as
references being like can you make it
look like I can't I can't wait to watch
this yeah no it was it's a movie I was
going to watch you said it's in Orson
Wells yeah he his quote it's I love you
know when it's you know it's a respected
filmmaker when the movie quote is from
him the best film I've ever
made I love I love wors and
Wells so much any clip you see of him
online is the funniest like I I sh you
not he's the funniest dude I've ever
heard speak I tried to find his book for
you today cuz I sent it to Mar I was in
the Strand trying to find it I couldn't
find was in rush but uh I'm howling on
the toilet reading that book it's so
funny it doesn't mean to be funny dude
it also it's just so funny something
about like a really big guy who like
won't admit like he won't admit he's
eating or something it's funny to me
where like he every night dinner he'd be
like he'd be like I just have a you know
have a a bite of sbet maybe you know and
then then he would go home and they'd
see his like at the hotel they'd be like
he ordered six ribe eyes last night and
there's something amazing about
that but he's so funny man he's so but I
I can't wait to watch this movie because
I've been meaning to watch it and I
don't know how it slipped through me but
all right so I'm flying back from United
or Buffalo I see a United sign it says
united
lgbtq we support equality and I'm like
as opposed to the other airlines that
are that are hateful is this is this an
issue on airlines I've never tried to
get on Delta they're like no juw no
juice I'm like I'm Diamond Medallion
they're like always diamonds with you
people always that's funny that's funny
jet
Jew but uh there's something there I
think yeah the thing about uh I find it
to be so insincere when these companies
are like we support everyone equally and
I'm like it it is illegal to not do that
yeah yeah yeah you can't you can't
discriminate it's 2023 yeah you're not a
hero well ran has that great bit what's
his bit his bit is I I went to a hotel
and there's a big sign on the wall like
we have we take everybody G black white
women you know whatever is this too
close to his bit well his is like yeah
that's that was a law passed in 196 four
um that and it makes me well his bit is
different because he goes the other way
he goes that makes me think you actually
do just think about these things like if
if I went to Red Lobster and like we
definitely don't jizz in the clam
chowder oh I heard that I have heard
that part okay so they definitely jiz in
the clamp chowder you know that's his
bit so I think that's different enough
yeah yeah I'll run to BU him but uh
that's funny yeah he's got great
then you got the diamond Jew thing is
great yeah um trying to avoid a 911 joke
here I know you're partying hard this
holiday season when you need to recover
fast turn to liquid IV it's not just for
people playing sports and running
marathons it's also for alcoholics it's
tyring shopping for gifts this holiday
season drinking holiday beer you need to
stay hydrated liquid IV gets you
hydrated two times faster than water
alone just one stick it's three times
the electrolytes of leading sports
drinks and vitamins nutrients everyday
Fitness I I drink this constantly I
get the sugar-free stuff because I'm
like usually working off the sugar from
a Manhattan or and a gron the night
before so I I like the sugar free but
they got white grape lemon lime it's
good stuff very good I I drink it just
once a day just in Casa even if I hung
over I drink two if I'm not hung over I
drink one just to get the old hydration
going liquid IV now comes in sugar-free
as I just said there's no glut soy dairy
or GMOs and no artificial sweeteners
either sugar is replaced with an amino
acid alose Ali alilo blend I don't know
what that is but trust the science folks
that's what I always say wink wink which
has the same taste and texture of table
sugar sorry I've been drinking yeah you
got that right that's why we need liquid
IV grab your liquid IV hydration
multiplier sugarfree in bulk nationwide
at Costco or you can get 20% off when
you go to liquid ib.com and use codee
drunk and check out that's 20% off
anything you order when you shop at
better hydration today using promo code
drunk liquid i.com nice great stuff I
highly recommend get on it you're going
to need it this holiday season you saw
the the snow white gal came out and
she's been harping on this and that and
diversity and now she's like I think
Disney's doing a great thing and all
that oh there you go wow you had that is
that your screen saver Jesus Christ so
uh in August 2023 I can't remember this
actress's name
I can't either she came out uh making
the new Rael zler Z thank you and she
says I mean you know the original
cartoon came out in 1937 and evidently
so there's a big focus on her love story
with a guy who literally stalks her it
was weird she said and she sort of
trashed the movie from 37 she was and
she said like yeah I used to have I had
a bit about this in my last special but
it's guess what it's it's 75
plus years old it's going to be a little
weird yeah yeah that's what
happened that's what progress is
changes yeah but I think the people
at Disney got to her was like you're
you're killing your opportunities here
so this month she came out and said the
cartoon is so beloved it's like a
Monumental moment in film history all
these amazing things that happened for
the uh for that film made Disney what it
is there she's like Towing the line now
she realizes she just could lose a
billion dollars on this movie my
my issue with the snow white stuff
personally is that just like okay
there's a very narrow margin for what
works as a hit I think like this movie
there's a reason it worked right anytime
they try to change anything about it it
doesn't work think look at the remakes
like you change anything you change like
the race of a character it might not hit
right it's like a joke you change one
word you change one thing it doesn't
mean that this is good or this is bad
it's just like it worked at a certain
time for a certain reason Snow White has
been a classic yeah right so you're in a
classic the next thing you get the the
line for whatever it is to to hit or not
hit is so thin yeah this is
Disney you're up with yeah and
now we deal in absolutes you know it's
like Willie Wonka
1978 had little people in it that's
abuse or whatever and then you're like
well Wily Wonka now has no midgets
that's unfair to midgets like you can't
they don't get a lot of casting
opportunities yeah the rules just keep
changing and then we keep yelling at
people as if they're the devil over a
decision and you're like well the rules
change I don't know like look at
Entourage you ever watch Entourage
you're like holy I can't believe
this went down but at the time it
was completely normal and everybody was
dying to get on that show and guess what
maybe that's like isn't that your
mission that things change yeah so and
if you got to go back and I rewat
Entourage and I crack the up I
think it's funny Funny's funny but if
you got to go back and find that's
bad in
1937 maybe that's a good sign and guess
what was bad in 1937
sure was not good and then
you think about all the stuff that
changed since of course like movies and
art is a reflection of the society
you're living in think about who had
rights back then think about who had a
lack of rights back then of course
is going to be different you have to you
know think about how many movies in
1940s don't have black people in them
you know or 1950s right so yeah was
different you have to you know have your
blinders on a little bit also recognize
that we were up and it's okay to
recognize we were up and admit it
you know yeah that's all right we
changed to for the better yeah yeah but
you can't get mad about the change and
then go back and go but yeah you know
like if a guy goes to jail for stealing
a car and then he does his time gets out
you can't go but you stole that car
you're like I know I served 20 years
right I'm trying to come out of prison
and and work at a grocery store and now
you're still mad about the car thing
yeah you hear that women
quit bringing up old well it's just
funny that she's trashing it but it's
like you're in it I get that like I it's
cool that she speaking from her heart
and being uh you know honest but at the
same time like is she though that's the
question well I think in initially she
was I don't know I think she was trying
to sound you think she was pandering I
think she was pandering to another group
then yeah I don't know maybe she was
maybe you're right maybe she was pandr
mean she's an actor that's the thing
that's what I'm talking about like
actors like there is a weird thing about
actors when you reach a certain level I
think like a working actor is different
than like a major star a working actor
has this humility from auditions and
having to just work and hustle all right
last bit and I'll leave you alone
please call me the bit don't don't leave
me alone okay uh I could hurt
myself I'm G to hurt myself you don't
come over oh great now I'm dying to come
over all right um uh yeah it's a hell of
an invitation yeah so you're cordially
invited to the day I may or may not kill
myself this will be a lot of fun can we
just watch uh Love Actually or something
all right I'd rather you hurt yourself
good point good
point you're looking at my notes yeah so
I uh I I brought the highres that photo
so we can actually see what you're
writing on these notes from this photo
sure do you want to do you want me to
share it no I know I mean is it it's not
set list I don't know no it's
just working on Races Beatles phone gym
driving self-esteem brexit stripper
crying yeah I think I I think I got a
few of those working set list or you're
working on jokes that's jokes I'm
working on so who knows if they went
anywhere I I did figure out the brexit
one I know that but all right uh last
joke I was at the zoo on the road my
friend that's uh so you got to do on the
road you got a Kil time and my friend
goes man these these zoos are like
prisons for animals and I was like well
actually they're kind of worse because
because Prison at least you have to
commit a crime that Panda didn't steal a
Camry you know and then in prison you
can get out on good
behavior that giraffe never hurt anybody
he's in here for life that's all I got
so I'm saying there's no reward for
being good in in the zoo in the zoo yeah
they don't let you out they're like we
keeping you you're a good elephant you
know is there a petting zoo comparison H
maybe it's a petting zoo yeah there's no
no comedy in this it's just an
observation really Mark's just an
environmental activist I'm with Peta now
he cares about the animals but yeah I I
feel like there's something there with
the it's worse than a it's worse than a
prison because they just scooped up this
kangaroo they he didn't even do anything
yeah these aren't like delinquent
animals these are just animals yeah like
we got guys who are like I went to jail
for for smoking weed man what the hell
and you're like well this kangaroo is
like I was just hanging out like I
didn't even do
anything I don't know I don't know where
they I just got picked up I got picked
up just trying to hang out the the brush
well that's why you're allowed to pet
the animals because oh if they were if
it was like a prison you ain't petting
those animals yeah good point that's
true that's that's a that's a dog fight
or a fight you're
at those animals aren't that bad either
all right maybe it's nothing I'll play
with
it I do have a peeve I know that was
point let's cut that out let's cut that
out I stink uh I peeve is uh when you're
out to eat and the waiter comes by and
says how is everything before you've
taken a bite
M hate that mhm yeah it's the
insincerity because now you have to lie
right I I'm with you it's the same you
have to lie I haven't tried it
yet but you got to do it up a little
like oh I haven't tried it yet I'm
getting there back you yeah don't worry
that conversation here yeah he's about
to his wife he's like that good for
you she's like your dick's still in your
pants well I think New York has
me because the service is so direct here
you know like you're in you're out
moving along shut up who cares with
other places they're like how are you
you good okay you need more water how do
you like that water you're like how do I
like the water I don't know it's good
get out of here like with Sam A1 yeah
yeah it's like sometimes too helpful
waiter is brutal I love his bit about uh
he's like Italians are tough as hell but
they're weird and and about some
stuff they're like I crack that guy in
the head with a baseball bat I don't
give a whoa what is that yogurt
good damn that's great I mean
he's got a million of them I love his
bit about how like this is like a walker
city in New York how like walk we we
run the city the Walkers not the
car the cars will be driving like oh my
God I almost got hit by that person yes
it's a great observation that's great so
true though how about his bit about uh
he's like black kids know the law they
sound black kids sound like police and
police sound like black kids that's an
amazing bit police are like I I can't
remember what the police say you know
they're like yo get get get get the hell
out of here what the you doing come
on and cops are like watch out that's a
618 or no black kids are like yeah sorry
I it up I've been drinking no
it's great I know we're both losing
well it's like midday we're not
eating before we come here we're just
at this morning this is why
people love the show so Peter said we
had a few comments you're not drinking
anymore blah blah blah you know pushes
us into rehab yeah we're doing the next
next EPS in rehab the producer Peter
sent us the drunkies which is the best
moment oh what you been sitting on this
been talking Jonathan masers for six
minutes other I might have other bits
too but it let's well that Zoo
thing
died thing maybe be something that I
can't find it I'm F it's hard we you
know all right what what do you got you
got another one well you pulling this up
or what are we doing yeah we're doing it
he's sending me access to
the you need access HH access tonight
Access
Hollywood is this funny anything I love
how dumb we're getting we're going to
have to dumb down articles for people to
comment that the only way people can
read articles in the future is if they
get the comment because everything's
about them you can see articles like yo
World War II are you smashing or
passing is there something there yeah
yeah I don't know
wrote down other thoughts we're good
with the drunkies here oh is there award
things or is this just like a revisiting
best drunk moment I will say that yam
episode might be the hardest I've
laughed on I've never seen you laugh
that hard in my life she was I've known
I've known you a long time she was
killing she was pretty great I've known
her for so long that it just it I it
just hit me we might have to have her
back at some point I would love to so
I'm sitting there and I see a she
got the baby the baby already doing that
stiff board
I know that that
move
said damn you're dying dude with
him to ca I just happen to be there
because my guy this is a great speech
yeah my guy going keep going yeah my guy
my guy right I'm loyal one saying I'm
loyal to kala hell
yeah that doesn't work but yeah yeah go
St Kil you got a relationship you got a
contract you got a friendship hang out
how do you do this you got to hold it oh
does it burn no you are you buzz right
now
yeah I just look at the dude oh Rex was
Hammer I saw Simon the other night he's
the we hung at the cellar he's
the best he's the best just the
best hang sure well I like
going he had a he had a spiral after
this episode he said he got recognized
by some
some dude stopped him like at a
big party and was like oh good yeah yeah
Oz with him The Mentalist what's
his name who is he should I say it first
open your eyes open your
[Music]
eyes that was crazy oh Rex is out
punch Rex in the
dick we were talking about earlier how
did you
get you know what they Tender tendering
Is it tendering
tendering this is crazy this is a great
podcast tend he ripped his
[Music]
cape God he so funny he the
sober one too I know we we did a ski
trip I we're all hammered the whole time
Ian Ian is sober and we were just dying
it was like having a court gesture in
the living room he was so fun such good
energy such a great guy oh yeah great
Energy Great Vibe the mustache he would
cook every night where did he cook you
he made parmesan chicken parm he
made like pasta I mean he just killed it
he was
great this is best puns
oh Matt Peter's
producing 100,000 Subs on YouTube
hell yeah that's a fatty
arbuck oh that took me a second fart on
that baby maybe that's why he was
crying grab his head hold
on that might kill a kid it's so fragile
yes you go to prison you
farted him to death dude idiot
supposed to be talking customer isn't
look nice
oh hope you edited that
[Music]
one Mark fading I'm
bored you're wasting
this
jeez I she's passing judg I felt bad
about like I want to say it too
but uh oh man that was that was an Aller
that was that was an altimer of Mark's
autism just coming out that was amazing
I was dying genuinely confused wait wait
wait are these the the best of farts oh
no Nate that Nate one haunted me this is
best and him excuse me this his best
fart all right what uh what what episode
are we on now cuz that was like 109 this
is 111 159 comes out this weekend we got
do we got to do it 160 oh 160 okay great
well
um I
can't you never seen on a blackc she
trying to talk about her journey to
weight loss I had to defend her there
yeah but that was
amazing I took a
shower and she kills me hold
on all
right just say this Nate looks like
sad the reason it's so good is cuz Nate
is like actually upset he was
pissed
who the guest
chamber I wonder why we don't have more
female
listeners that was that is
disgusting that fart that's just a hot
look that was a chunky fart yeah that
had some
gurgle all right Theo that was a that
was a real one
you never knew that yeah I I blocked it
out I blocked it
out
silent
mik I didn't hear
it that's it's a low
moment that was a bad F watching these
I'm like this is a good show I I get why
people watch it or listen by the way I
like that our best of is Mark being
like I know our best of is a dude just
farting well I love the idea of Nate
just he's doing a show of of Seinfeld
Gaffigan Sebastian and him at the
Hollywood Bowl they just sold out two
shows and I'm farting on him I I feel
he's not happy here he wasn't happy this
God bless you Nate sorry Nate that was
his Jonathan major moment Me farting on
him I'm a great man doing great shows
and I get farted on by Mark Norman oh
Nate we love you this is best reaction
oh here we go it's just the same
Cliff Matt Peters producing it's more
conversational it's more whatever it is
right hold on wait wait it's the same
I mean it is the great
reaction I mean just I mean the head
shake that was like when I told my dad I
was doing comedy I had a second cousin
who was pretty hot would you second
cousin really mother I tried
Miss bad hates us godamn sis you might
crazy as a damn empty
wallet yeah okay now oh the the
69 I'll
blow man Bobby Le's comedy
[Music]
gold it's hard to beat Bob Bobby on the
it's hard to Beat
Bobby Bobby re what the
and
what what has this become I know well
the booze is
Flowing Bobby right Sam's color
commentating that's a
[Laughter]
reaction anything yeah hey Winnie and
the cat oh oh hey
Sam good
referee might you might be Herb Dean no
one with wingy yeah wow you really
protected love that old ass dog
oh pause for a second in is this
something I was giving my girlfriend
for buying stuff for Winnie I'm
like dude she's 16 stop buying her
jackets you know like she 12
jackets stop buying her jacket she goes
you know I was like she's gonna be gone
any moment she goes well I buy you stuff
oh that's a bit maybe there's that's a
bit that's almost as good as my Zoo
stuff this is uh P salacuse reactions oh
all right we've reached the low
point this is like the best
documentaries everyone goes to the
bathroom sound design all right here we
go hell yeah that's a wait wait it's got
the same is you're all with reruns
already all right normally I try to
really uh fart on that baby maybe that's
why this is this is this is a wrong
you're in the wrong folder do we have a
reward for worst audio
engineer where's Google
heard all right here we go that's
it oh we haven't seen Noel Miller
yet you didn't call him out on his
map that was racist dude that
was
we're
idiots that was more
subtle did you happen to watch that uh
Headliners only I haven't seen it yet is
it good it's fun it's fun because they
show them on the way up and you can see
all this crazy footage of them as kids
bombing and stuff but uh I mean I I just
love rock so much and I'm not Kevin Hart
I you know he's great but I you know I
grew up with rock so I'm like I want to
see all the rock stuff so uh it's cool
to watch it's cool to see him coming up
I got to check it out it's fun Rock's
the man he's the man and then there's
something else like oh yeah this there a
World War
II I'm turning into Tony Soprano like I
see World War II I watch it yeah I
think we're getting we're getting up
there is that old is that old gu
cuz I just think these are people these
were 18-year-old dudes on the beach of
nor different lives than us yeah oh yeah
they would sign up for the war because
they were like bored well it was like a
point of Pride that too I just feel like
the country is in a different place I
just feel like oh yeah when people talk
about like a Civil War and I'm like
shut the up stop putting it out
there that's a peeve people putting it
out there what's
that Trump off the ballot in uh
Colorado and by the way that will
we're pre-recording this so this
could be resolved in a couple weeks but
like then people be like is this going
to mean Civil War I'm like does
everything have to mean civil
War I didn't see that
wow Civil War have you seen this I think
I'll set this one out what is this a24
is movie called Civil War oh Jesus the
blue States die on day
one I'm just like I have a problem with
this war and they're like yeah right gun
ownership is problematic well I have a
gun 824 wow o the United States of
Puerto
Rico hey Offerman a boy all right
it maybe see Alex Garland is he the
president yes well that's fun IDE all
right I'm in and California got together
oh bad premise from the union already
not believe
should have been Florida the two states
that hate each other
yeah oh X moina good
movie and it's in New
York a24 does make good they do
I'll watch
this hey Kirsten Dunst look at that
movies are different than people
tweeting it though constantly being like
Civil War and I'm like dude you got a
lot of followers can you cut it out I
know know I know can can you can you
stop trying to get people to want to
have a civil war maybe well luckily
we're too lazy you know it's going to be
like well we are there's some people who
live for this that's true
there's some people who are like I'm
dying to have a civil war there's
there's the capital storm people then
there's the people who are like oh the
Christmas tree was lit at 30 Rock Let's
Go protest that you're like Jesus I wish
I had your motivation no you don't I
guess not but I you're on the road
you're tired from traveling and doing
gigs I guess I would use it to go to the
gym or maybe uh to better yourself and
not be a boring piece of
you mean do Taio or write a write a
novel something no let's be real none of
us are writing a
novel
maylet something you start a novel and
then on page 13 you're like I'm good I
got nothing to say I got nothing yeah
hey it was the best of times it was the
queefs all right cut print start of
something all right we have a
start the ending A Tale of Two shitties
he there we go I'll tell
you anything else do we miss anything I
think we got we got some movies it was a
good year we talk movies so hard here
but I like movies I it happens
and we're going to make a movie dude
yeah we're going to make a movie that's
the plan it's already uh pretty much
written we're going to tweak yeah but we
got it but now we have to deal with the
people that take forever yeah what
writing the movie is easy it's getting
it made that's hard so how do you deal
with like getting notes from people you
know that aren't as
funny we hav we're not there yet it's
coming but yeah we'll see we'll see how
we deal with it I think I think we'll
start a civil war yeah gay 24 I think we
do what we want to do and then just give
it to them and then when they go well
how about this how about that we go oh
that's that's very that's a great idea
what if instead of your idea I wipe my
ass with your pages yeah and Mark and I
came up with a better joke there you go
exctly I think I think you just have to
yes and I think yes anding is the move
and just be like oh okay but we've not
we're not there yet but I think you just
kind of are positive and you don't
belittle people cuz that's kind of like
a belittling thing regardless to be like
we don't know how we feel about this you
don't you bring a better energy yeah
definitely you got to you got to Plate
you got to rub the back go yeah you're
people in the past and never again I'd
rather not make something than work with
people that up our yeah and I
think we always have the back the card
in the back pocket like we'll just put
it online off and they're like okay
okay okay because I think I think a lot
of these uh streamers and TV they're all
scared of the internet I think someone's
going to make this too I think I think
we're going to be in a good place I'm
not I'm not worried not not worried at
all cut cut the mark and eye on battle
fatigue is like Civil War yeah
do it the movie didn't go here's two a
great 2024 guys there you go to you
maybe next year you'll actually drink
part of your
drink yeah I'm sorry I made you such a
bad drink Sal I thought they were good
I'm going to pop this just for the
visual yes tasty thank you but he's got
kids to raise I love a good to grown but
hey we're not done yet
folks you going to pop that oh yeah
is that all right okay you're going to
break some of the pull pull up a
good drinking speech there qes while
you're uh while you're get out with
Baldwin garan Ross I'm gonna shoot this
like Alec Baldwin hopefully I don't hit
a co-star all right what do you got
there
Sally get Pino On Any Given Sunday life
is a game of
inches that's what I tell my
wife right here we
go let's could go either way I'm I'm
going for that middle light bulb on that
uh that hanger
there have you seen Maestro is it good I
mro I never heard of it it's a Bradley
Cooper movie oh is that about Lenny he
got accused of jewface oh right I think
that wasn't
real oh wait a minute musolini what what
are happened to this uh drinking speech
I want
speech it's going to be an Italian you
know right all right well we had a good
run I mean Matt Matt has been phoning in
for weeks now this is really
unacceptable all right what do we got
okay so we got a bottle of champagne
here to
2024 melini can we get a better energy
please what are you doing here what the
is this an Italian dictator yeah we
should have been more specific than just
motivational techically that is
motivational but for who what happened
to the uh Any Given Sunday
all
right okay alpacino you've heard of him
Any Given Sunday is a football coach
inspirational speech a fun scene how
long is
it four minutes
great Jamie Fox pre-stroke I love Jamie
Fox one inch at a time Mark yes I can't
do it for you I'm too
old not to have a baby
Dennis Quaid yeah dude Jesus how old's
he what year is this
[Music]
96 oh that guy Jim Brown Jim Brown
scariest guy
ever pop it wellow didn't know if we
were getting somewhere is there a cook
is there a finale don't make me do the
zoo bit again us to pieces for that for
that that
inch
H
inch here we go the difference
between living
and between living and
dying yeah we should do um s of a woman
instead we should have done take a
[Music]
flamethrower I'm just getting warmed up
pull it up
okay we're gonna have to cut all this
out aren't we no oh yeah is that
legal all right we
finagle we got nothing out of that we
got a couple of lines okay here we go
I'm sure this will be 18 and a half
minutes it
is but there is
a what is this Pacino day one more one
more we didn't get to this one slow down
back with hisil between his legs but I
say you are executing his
soul no no leave this because he's not a
bad
man you hurt this boy you're going to be
bad bugs the lot of you Harry
Jimmy Trent wherever you are out there
you too
ah Stand Down Mr SL that guy's great
y as I came in here I heard those words
cradle of
leadership well when the bow breaks the
cradle will fall we've lost all our
listeners make us a man Creator
El no no no come on you're
you're killing this you pull up uh Robin
Williams in Dead Poet Society I'm
shooting this right at your
faceu is not going to get that man what
the Injustice for all
yeah because I'm going to get him I've
never seen this one I've never seen this
either spoiling it all right pause it
Mark pop it we've got all right well I
was hoping for a nice moment here we've
gone through four movies have got
nothing Jesus Christ all right should be
made up
2024 just get the kids cheering for
sake something give me something
there got to be a moment here it is pull
up Jurassic Park
uh no no hold on uh there's got to be
some some great
Rudy that sound is I do like that sound
I know you're seen a fun movie slow clap
Rudy is too cute come on just
pop it who gives Shing you to
get the YouTube premium or whatever the
hell YouTube Red all right okay so here
we are 2024 thanks for watching we might
be drunk get Bo DGA cat we appreciate
you listening hit
it we love you out there pot of the Year
great guests Good Times great times
great drinking with you pop it to
another great year hey to little people
everywhere getting their shot you hear
that Dinklage and big people
yeah and mediumsized people there you go
and oh oh I hit it all
right we couldn't do it without you
thank you everybody thank you guys and
see us on the road bye Bodega cat
whiskey bodat whiskey.com I think I got
uh Madison this weekend Madison comedy
club Philly
uh Dana Beach I don't usually
Matt helps out with this part but he's
been phoning it in for quite some time
I'm drunk really we might be uh I don't
know where else I'm going to be this
month oh Stanford Connecticut Omaha
OKC Addison and in Texas
everywhere Salt Lake City Irvine and the
specials in Boston I believe it's sold
out but I love you guys Mark where you
gonna be buddy and happy New Year Mark
Norman comedy.com by way I'm using that
punch up live guy he's the best he's a
good egg but uh I'm I'm way over my head
here yeah it's a lot it's a lot I'm
clueless but I'm going to be all over
the road Tampa
Phoenix uh Boise Idaho Houston San
Antonio Charlotte Lexington Atlanta
Raleigh Austin
Tucson uh oh Charlottesville Charleston
El Paso Albuquerque Memphis Little Rock
Knoxville
Chattanooga Syracuse to name a few uh
get some swag while we got it Bodega cat
sam.com for tickets Mark Norman
comedy.com for tickets and uh bodegacat
uh whiskey.com for the whiskey and uh
great
energy last time I give salak use a
drink what the hell happened
he's going to be slitting his wrist in a
bathtub in two minutes we're killed it
we got Jonathan major on the next app
two I feel bad when I said I think he's
going to beat me up uh
but you know uh Been a Good Year we
appreciate you guys we're grateful to
you guys for listening we're grateful
for you Matt Peters and even salamona
for fumbling these Google searches uh
like TIY Barbera before he learned how
to carry a football and uh you know we
uh we appreciate all the listeners we
hope you have a great New Year we hope
you're safe we hope you're healthy and
we hope you get what you want and there
we go When Harry Met Sally that's a
happyend count it down who's the count
we had Dick Clark he died who's is it
CEST
and they got Andy conen Anderson Cooper
right okay there you go Meg Ryan would
you yeah of course all right out of
respect yes how about you yeah
definitely look at that she's cute she's
goddamn adorable yeah buddy all right
well hey well we're here we're queer we
miss you already happy New Year thank
you guys thank you we'll see you next
year heyy folks we might be drunk really
drunk hey hey folks we might be drunk
face comedy